oh is it going I hastily pushed the play
button before it was really ready hi um
classic grace in a car stuck in traffic
in aw such nice
8:13 in the morning here and I was
supposed to be at a place at 8:00 a.m.
and I'm still about 10 miles away from
my brain cannot compute when I should
leave my apartment to get to place this
yet it'll get there hopefully it was
raining this morning what everyone told
me it doesn't do that here everyone is a
liar how are you guys holding up I'm
tired I am tired it's been decided by me
oh man I had a super busy day say that I
might end up actually day league racing
in of my car that sounds disgusting but
yeah I have like five meetings back to
back to back and so I might try and find
like a quiet parking lot so I brought my
camera with me and everything in my
backpack at my laptop so we'll see what
happens
I'm just checking in saying hey mostly
because all of the radio stations have
gone to commercial and I hate
commercials so I thought I would do this
to occupy my wall street time okay guys
so grabbing a good what is it Thursday
God where does the time go
it just keeps on ticking you know like
that song
Madonna song I don't know I'm talking
many more by E